hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
over the next half an hour we're going
to be talking through the headlines with
the daily mirror economist
susie boniface and the conservative
commentator tim montgomery so a very
good evening to both of you nice to see
you both so to those front pages then
and the eye claims to have exclusive
details of the government's plan to get
the uk
out of lockdown due to be announced the
week after next
but not to be outdone the mirror carries
similar details
including that social mixing could be
allowed again by may
the sun seems to be even more optimistic
they say the pubs
could be back open by april though i see
the words outdoor beers there at the
bottom
the daily mail celebrates the likelihood
of reaching the goal to vaccinate
15 million elderly and vulnerable people
by
monday the headline is that's a jab well
done
the daily express ties the two stories
together suggesting the reason lockdown
might be able to be eased is partly
because the vaccine rollout
has been so rapid though according to
the guardian there are worries that
people
under 65 who have underlying conditions
may not have been
correctly classified and may not be
called when it's their turn
the daily telegraph speaks to the health
secretary matt hancock who says the aim
is to make
covid become manageable on a
year-to-year basis
much like the flu the times have seen
government projections which estimate
that the number of people in hospital
with the virus is likely to half
or more within the next month and the
financial times reports that in the
first
phase of the pandemic last year the uk
economy
sunk to its worst state in 300 years but
has now outpaced expectations with its
recovery
and the star condemns a postman who it
alleges refused to help an elderly woman
who'd fallen
on his route because he was too tired
so susie boniface and tim montgomery are
here with me to
tiptoe through those front pages um
susie you've picked out
the times first of all there's a lot of
looking into the future in the papers
isn't there and a certain amount of
of projection and perhaps speculation
but the times is focusing
on what they say is internal government
projections about hospitalization so
what are they saying here
yep they're saying there's going to be a
falling covid patience because the r
number has fallen below one
and i'm i'm sorry i'm probably going to
get tweeted by a load of sky viewers
after this about how
gloomy and what a killjoy i'm being
because there's so much
good news as it's being presented in the
papers today about
great news about jabs great news about
the covered rate falling great news that
may be the end of lockdown
but it's some of it is it's doing my
head in
because in this times piece about how
the numbers are falling
it also points out that this is the
first time the r rate has been below one
since july and that means that a
killer disease has been circulating and
multiplying
out of our control for seven months
nothing is good news when that has been
happening yes it's great there are some
some falls in covered patients now
and the numbers in hospitals are coming
down but the numbers in hospitals were
so critically appalling
that it you know an intensive care nurse
was having to look after three patients
at a time instead of
one and that means none of those three
patients are getting truly intensive
care
they're getting one-third of intensive
care
and intensive care nurses are doing 12
and a half hour shifts
um it's just nothing about this is good
news i'm afraid
um it's good to some extent but only
because what it was was so appallingly
awful
well yes i mean yes it does do you take
that point tim that
we are starting from a pretty appalling
standpoint when we look about
things improving but nevertheless um it
is promising that
uh hospital numbers do look like they're
heading the right direction from a very
high point as susie is making clear
there
absolutely susie does not have to wait
until twitter she comes off this program
to twitter to have someone
disagree with her look of course what
we've been through as a nation
um the nhs frontline staff they've
suffered enormously and you know we all
admire what they've done we all grieve
with the families who've lost um
loved ones but my goodness we need some
good news
you know we've all been in lockdown for
nearly two months now we want
to believe that the sacrifices that
we're all making have been worth it
and we have these stories in the times
in the mail which show that we are
getting on top of this virus at last we
have to be cautious because
i think we feel we've been here before
and the viruses has returned
but it's good that infection rates are
really beginning to come down
largely because of the impact of the
lockdown rather than the vaccine
but then we have the effect of the
vaccine that hopefully should start
coming through
as well we're two days ahead of the
government's target of
vaccining all the key and older
vulnerable groups
and that's something really to celebrate
there's something there's so many things
that have gone wrong
during this lockdown but this vaccine
roll out
the creation of the vaccines themselves
this is good news and so
susie and understandably um you know is
concerned about all the things that have
gone wrong but
we need hope we need light at the end of
the tunnel and these newspaper reports
suggest that there is real light to look
forward to
and so those headlines in the times in
the mail what we saw just there about
hospital cases coming down and the the
success so far of the vaccination
program susie inevitably gonna prompt
speculation about
when uh the lockdown restrictions may be
eased
we're told we're gonna get this roadmap
from the prime minister a week on monday
um the the mirror and some of the other
papers already
trying to look ahead to what might be
announced so what's the mirror telling
us they've got the
cheeky headline there the joy of six
part two they say
yeah there's a lot of cheeky headlines
knocking around um we could also do
with optimism as well some accuracy and
um some realism uh the vaccines that
have
been brilliant to have had them so far
for the 15 or so million people who've
had the first ones already that's
fantastic and that means they've got
some protection but those vaccines
aren't completed
until they've had two doses and in the
next few months
all the people have had one dose and
there's 14 and a half million so far who
haven't had their second doses they have
to start getting the second doses which
means our vaccination rate is going to
shelve off slightly from the
exponentially brilliant rate it's been
up till now
so our rate of vaccination and
protection of our population is going to
steady a little bit um and we're talking
about the lifting of lockdown but what
they're actually talking about here is
this is the
the road map out of the lockdown which
boris johnson's promised by february the
22nd
two days ago he told the bbc uh at a
public press conference that was
televised
that he wasn't going to reveal details
about it
now it appears in several of the
newspapers his
office has been briefing out details of
it which means it hasn't gone through
parliament and it's not been publicly
admitted that this is the plan but yet
we're letting it be heard
ten days before we're going to publish
it this is the sort of thing we're
looking at that's not helpful or
beneficial
particularly i'm not sure if we know
exactly where it's come from certainly
the daily mirror is
quoting um professor neil ferguson for
some of the the reason they're talking
about the lifting of restrictions in the
way that they have
though i should say tonight that uh
government sources are saying that no
decisions have been made they don't
recognize these reports
but tim there are a number of them
aren't though the sun as well is talking
about
pubs possibly opening in two months for
outdoor uh
beers and food and i think the eye as
well is talking about
what might happen what do you make of
this i mean
all the messages we seem to be getting
from the government at the moment is
we're not going to give you details
we're going to take it very cautiously
so do you think that these these papers
are on the right track or not
i think what is happening across
government there's only
real one big sort of support
area of unity in government and that's
that schools must be
the priority i'm sure any parents
watching who've been homeschooling their
kids over
the last few weeks will be glad to hear
that other than that i think there's
still quite a lot of active discussion
in government about how quickly and what
sort of parts of the
economy reopen when and i suspect
what some of the newspapers are picking
up from their various sources
ministerial and others inside government
are fragments of those um discussions
but
i think it was very premature uh for us
to
look at any of these stories and bank on
them being true i think the government
still wants to make further progress
and we don't want any slip up in the
vaccination roll out
and so i would urge any readers to
read for example the sun's front page
tomorrow about pubs reopening
and not be too excited too quickly and
you know keep caution
about exactly what's next okay and the
daily telegraph looks ahead in a
different kind of way don't they
susie they're quoting the health
secretary talking about how in the
future
he hopes that the country will be able
to deal with coronavirus
which is one of the dumbest interviews i
think i've ever read and i've read a lot
of them
um he's entitled to his opinion of
course and yes it's possible in this
country that
uh we would have the health service and
the wealth and the access to vaccines
that
covid doesn't need to affect us too much
but in the years to come
uh you know we may be well vaccinated
but the rest world will not be
africa for example which has i think
eight of the 15
fastest developing economies in the
world with which we need to do business
in the years to come
is expect so far has only vaccinated
0.06 of its 1.3 billion population
and we need our trading partners to be
healthy
if we're going to trade i mean our
economy is going to be protected never
mind the moral imperative
sorry to dive in susie i just want to
give tim a chance to come back and we
really ought to be going to a break but
tim what's your take on that
well um i i think um susie's a bit harsh
on matt hancock
but what is absolutely true is that we
do need to help the rest of the world
and be vaccinated as well and i'm glad
that the government has contributed i
think a billion pounds to the
international vaccination
program and we have to realize that we
have to keep
committing to that this is a not a
project that's going to be over in a
year we have to use our aid budget
and our other resources as a country to
be not to just be generous
but to show the solidarity we need with
poorer nations so that we are all
healthy
in this era where kobe isn't going to go
away okay and and the debate at which
that help might start is is going to go
on as well isn't it and we're going to
take a break right now um
coming up though don't go anywhere uh
we're going to talk about the outlook
for the economy after the pandemic and
whether it's right
to increase taxes we're going to be
talking about that next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone they they can't arrest
everybody
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
you saying that doesn't say hitler
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight susie boniface
and tim montgomery
and we're turning to the front of the ft
next time aren't we and um
today some fairly grisly growth figures
came out
showing uh the kind of shrinkage to the
economy
last year as a result of the pandemic at
a 300-year low
says the ft they were they were fairly
grim figures weren't they
yeah there's no you know hiding from the
fact that the economic impact
on the uk economy despite the fact that
the government has thrown
everything including the kitchen sink
with its furlough program and other
measures
to try and keep you know us all employed
and
the economic you know output continuing
as much as possible
but you know we have had as a country
one of the steepest declines of
of any economy i think that's partly
because of the
extent of some of the early problems
that the government had
in handling the crisis but i think there
are other reasons as well britain is a
particularly open economy
uh london has been particularly badly
hit by the economy
as city and services have suffered and
so yeah there's a long way to go
to i think pick up the pieces from where
the economy has been let alone the
educational impact
and the other downsides of the covert
crisis well yeah and susie there will be
a lot of businesses that have
gone under or feel horribly mortally
wounded by
by what's going on but there is a hope
that there will be some kind of bounce
back
if and when we return to normal
normality there are there are hopes for
the future aren't there
there are i'm not quite sure what
they're founded upon
rishi sunak in this piece is quoted as
being cautiously optimistic
about the future the mail today was
reporting that we're going to spend
spend spend
although one in four of us are
struggling to make ends meet according
to the same newspaper
um i don't know why c next cautiously
optimistic because
you know if you have been on an airplane
and an engine fell off
and then the pilot comes out and
announces he stuck it back on with
sticky tape and it'll be fine he's
causing you optimistic we should take
off now
you would say no no that would be a
terrible idea the reason that britain
has had such a terrible economic impact
from coronavirus is due to the way as
tim said
the government handles coronavirus the
reason we still have had lockdowns the
reason they have been so long and so
damaging is because they were so late
and that is why we have the economic
impact we have with people like in
greater manchester who've been locked
down for a year not two months
where publicans are going under um and
if we these are the people who crash the
bus you know
to mix my metaphors why would you trust
them to keep on driving the bus
and that's not a political point that's
just a that's just a practical point if
someone has crashed
your bus you wouldn't let them drive you
on destination would you
you'd change the bus driver at least if
not the best okay very quick very quick
come back on that
tim she's relentlessly negative on every
topic
this evening but look the government
have gone through
wrong the government have got some
things wrong and i would acknowledge
them i have in this program
but on the vaccination program on help
for people through things like the
furlough scheme the success of universal
credit during this
period that the government have got many
things right as well and governments
all over the world breaking news for
snoozy have got things
wrong as well well that is 10 of the
working population of this country have
had not a single penny of help from the
government
i i'm one of them susie i felt in the
cracks as well but we have to
acknowledge the bigger
picture of people
we're going to continue this
conversation um at 11 30 but we are out
of time
now susie and tim always good to see you
both and see you again very shortly
thank you